I'm Olivia from the Global Agenda
Council on brain and cognitive sciences
I'm also 2011 young global leader of a
World Economic Forum and our work in
this summit is to try and understand why
the burden of mental disorders and brain
disorders is not considered enough in
the media by political leaders and
leaders in general there is a true
burden at the economic human and
societal level that is related to these
brain disorders issues and so far there
is very little attention compared to the
importance this question so we tried to
address it at the neurological level but
also a cognitive or some of the work
we're doing on the neuroscience decision
making is quite interesting for that
matter and this is why we enjoy
interacting with other councils for
example there's decision-making and
value on the one on digital media one on
media and Maggie munication because we
want to understand what is going on in
people's head whether we're talking
about a citizen or a decision-maker so
that they don't consider decision and
this is very interesting because it
mixes very neurological approach to the
brain but also the more cognitive your
comics social psychology nice thing that
we're trying to do in connecting the lab
or medical reception with what we're
doing in the field in public policy
making